la situation sanitaire en espagne à
présent la catalogne a vécu hier soir sa
première nuit sous couvre-feu le
gouvernement régional a décidé de lever
cette mesure face à un ralentissement de
la sixième vague mais d'autres
restrictions sont toujours en vigueur
sur place les détails à barcelone de
clémentine ans
désormais les barcelonais pavot rentrer
chez eux alors qu'ils veulent le
gouvernement catalan a décidé de lever
le couvre feu qui était en vigueur de 1h
à 6 heures du matin dans les villes les
plus touchées de la région c'était une
mesure qui avait été prise les autorités
catalanes juste avant noël pour freiner
la contamination au kobus 19 car il faut
rappeler qu'en décembre la région avait
dû faire face à un nombre de
contaminations très élevé alors
aujourd'hui la situation est toujours
très préoccupante avec une incidence de
4315 cas pour 100000 habitants ces deux
dernières semaines ce qui peut sembler
beaucoup mais le gouvernement catalan
considère que la sixième vague est en
train de ralentir et c'est pourquoi il a
décidé d'alléger le quotidien de ses
habitants je propose d'écouter les
barcelonais qui sont plutôt partagés sur
la question
moi je l'aurais prolonger quelques jours
de plus jusqu'à ce que baisse les
contaminations je ne trouve pas que ce
soit une bonne idée de lever le
couvre-feu au nom des droits civils
quand on voit toutes les pertes de
liberté possible et imaginable que nous
avons vécu
cette absurde de limiter nos libertés
c'est une mesure pour éviter l'effet est
illégal dans la rue mais c'est leur
problème
c'est bien qu'il n'y ait plus de
couvre-feu au royaume uni ils ont retiré
toutes les restrictions
ces mesures ne fonctionne pas autant
qu'il le dise
je n'ai pas le droit de rentrer dans une
salle de sport à cause de la jauge et
maintenant ils enlèvent le couvre-feu il
devrait rester en vigueur jusqu'au jour
où le coronavirus sera parti de manière
générale on assiste à une tendance à
l'allègement des restrictions en espagne
par exemple dans la région de la
cantabrie au nord du pays les autorités
ont décidé de réduire l'utilisation du
pass sanitaires et puis le premier
ministre espagnol lui-même pedro sanchez
se montre beaucoup moins armistice
vis-à-vis de l'évolution de la sixième
vague dans le pays mais si les autorités
semblent moins préoccupés elles
maintiennent tout de même les
restrictions en espagne par exemple sur
tout le territoire le port du masque est
obligatoire à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur et puis la catalogne impose
encore plus de mesures entre le co vite
19 les discothèques sont toujours fermés
depuis un mois les rassemblements
sociaux sont limitées à 10 personnes et
puis il y à des jauges d'occupation de
50% dans les restaurants et de 70% dans
le monde de la culture du sport et les
commerces toutes ces mesures seront
d'ailleurs revu la semaine prochaine par
le gouvernement catalan la question de
prolonger les restrictions sera donc le
nouveau sur la table